what is up everybody its Anna Mac and
welcome to another episode of the week's
best anime videos which is a weekly
newscast here on our channel links are
in the description recommendations go in
the comments and know there is nothing
at all different about me today okay
okay fine I'm trying out some anime
hairstyles so let me know what you think
down in the comments now the biggest and
most frustrating news last week was
despite claims by Netflix that $0.70
season 2 would be coming out on Friday
February 17th that did not happen what
actually happened was what we knew would
happen is the only thing that was made
available the only new material is
actually the size of a holy war TV
special a four episode TV special that
aired last summer in Japan even though
here in anime upper we knew that there
would be no second season because we've
been monitoring the official Japanese
website for the seven deadly sins and
there was no information whatsoever on a
second season what really did frustrate
a lot of us is how Netflix approached
this release they clearly labeled this
TV special as a season 2 they promoted
it as a season 2 it was thrown in all
the media official media was reporting
that it was a season 2 so a lot of fans
who didn't do further research assumed
that it would be a full season 2 with 24
25 episodes they waited some of them
waited up all night to for the actual
show to become available and they were
sorely disappointed when they realized
that there was no season 2 we actually
uploaded a video about this on Friday
morning and that video already has
almost 12,000 views and so many comments
that we're getting of people being
frustrated and disappointed with this
mad at Netflix because Netflix clearly
misled everyone and falsely claimed to
have a season 2 as a fan of the show
myself I completely understand that
people are frustrated and angry because
I've heard that some people renewed
their membership to Netflix for that
month for this month
only so they could see the second season
of the seven deadly sins because as we
know I'm a Netflix customer and Netflix
is a paid service so a lot of people
feel ripped off because they were
expecting us 7 Deadly Sins season 2
netflix actually had this four episode
miniseries listed
as season two all the way up until
yesterday and then yesterday they
finally changed it to signs of a holy
war so now it is finally properly
labeled but like we said in there [ __ ]
marketing push for February they were
labeling it a season two then when it
was released they labeled it as season
two for several days and this led to a
lot of confusion and a lot of
frustration as a customer of Netflix
myself and as the seven deadly sins fan
I think that Netflix definitely owes
everyone an apology and they need to
clarify why they misrepresented this
season if it is a miniseries just call
it a miniseries what's the big deal but
anyway those are my thoughts I'd love to
hear what you guys think down in the
comments let me know back on saturday i
uploaded my response to a code geass
hate video made by DX fan six one nine
now of course I have nothing against the
expand personally or his fans or his
channel but I felt that the tone of his
video was very over-the-top and
provocative and after several of you
guys asked me to respond to this video I
decided to make my response and overall
I would say I'm just amazed with all the
support we've been getting on this video
I think we got over 350 likes in one day
which is a new record for the channel
and we are now reaching for that 500
like mark which is amazing and while we
did get some hate comments we also got a
lot of constructive criticism and from
what I was able to see on both DX fans
video in the comments and in our own
comment is that the vast majority of his
fans are very reasonable people that
they you know look at the arguments they
said that we both had valid arguments
that gave their own opinion and yeah
they just seemed like very reasonable
people which makes me think that a lot
of the expense other content is surely
reasonable because his fans are
reasonable themselves however I stand by
what I said I think his video was out of
line and I think my video put him back
in line but I'd love to hear what you
guys think so let me know down in the
comments back on Wednesday of last week
we finally had our epic REM vs. Emilia
best girl debate on the black Critic
guys Channel with Tony and anime recon
defending Ram and myself and Briggs from
all-day anime defending Emilia now this
debate was a lot of fun it was intense
it was passionate and I love seeing your
feedback down in the car
of course we feel that we want they feel
like they want but I'll leave the link
in the description if you want to check
it out and decide for yourself now I
know what you must be thinking dude Anna
Mac you're doing these debates you're
making these roast videos
what are you turning into another double
for anime and I just want to know no I
just want to reassure you guys that is
not the case now let me just put on the
suit jacket for a second do that a
little chilly in here okay just I got to
do something first
now stop drop drop drop in other news
the anime man finally released his 2016
summer and fall double seasonal anime
roundup this is definitely a detailed
and useful video be sure to check it out
although as to say I disagree a bit with
Joey's analysis of re0 he seems to
dislike the first few episodes in the
last few episodes and his favorite part
of the season was the middle part where
I am actually the exact opposite I like
the first view on last two episodes but
that middle part were the tone shifts
from an action fantasy anime to some
kind of like psychological horror slash
blood and guts anime I didn't really
like that part that was kind of strange
to me although I am looking forward to a
second season and I did enjoy the show
overall and I'm actually working on a
new video right now that will be
counting down the top 10 unsolved
mysteries in our easy row mysteries that
I really want to see resolved in season
2 definitely stay tuned for that later
on this week this week Brent from Brent
fandoms our fellow Rand cafe member
uploaded a really unique review of the
anime drifters in this video she
actually combines a review with a speed
sketch of one of the characters and she
is really a talented artist and a
talented reviewer so you definitely have
to watch this video link in the
description and my favorite envy for
this week is not even an MV and it's not
even from this week but I just
discovered this week that the youtuber
known as Pele K official actually made a
metal version a metal cover of the song
sanctuary from Kingdom Hearts this video
is from like 2013 so it's several years
old but the song is so amazing it does
such an awesome job that I have to
feature it here on the week's best anime
videos I mean just listen to some of
this
[Music]
whoopee
I mean that is just amazing so so badass
I loved it
be sure to check out this guy's channel
the link is in the description and he
did actually upload a brand new cover
this week of the theme from mystic
messengers so this guy is still
uploading regularly he's killing it be
sure to check him out and that's it for
this week guys if you enjoyed these
videos be sure to LIKE and subscribe and
do you think that I should grow up my
hair to look like Bella Kay let me know
down in the comments and until next time
see ya nope l club space cowboys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]